my back.
O, delete that. I almost gave up on this
project entirely. Damn it, friends. I
think we're ready.
[Music]
Hey friends, what up? So, I've got a
very, very special challenge to share
with you all today. I'm going to learn
how to do a cirtole po routine in only 2
hours.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video I'm going to
take on a pretty major challenge and see
if I can pull it off. But before we dive
in, I just want to give a quick shout
out to the friends of the channel. Big
thanks to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Paroter, Light
Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible. You
can learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. And special
thanks to the non-b businessiness friend
of the channel, Becca Becklanin. Thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel, my work, and my mission. So,
let me lay down a wee bit of context for
this one. About a week ago, Cirtole
Casting published a listing for a koi
specialist. It appears that this is
casting for a show called O based out of
Las Vegas. And as it turns out, there is
video online of this specific act from
O. And upon reviewing this game tape, I
was kind of surprised to find number one
that the act is not all that technical.
And number two, that the dance
requirements around it aren't nearly as
technical as I was expecting either.
Now, in all transparency, I have
absolutely no intentions of applying for
this job. But it did get my gears
turning and thinking, hey, maybe I could
learn just the routine. And so I have
booked the dance studio close to where I
live here on the edge of DC for the next
2 hours. And I'm going to jump in there
and see if I can learn this routine.
Let's see how this goes for me.
Yeah.
Awesome. Let's get started.
All right. So,
I am all warmed up and it's time to
start figuring out a course of action on
this. So, first and foremost, clearly
fire is not going to work inside of the
studio. I figure that the closest I can
get to that indoors are uh these kind of
long strip poi that show off images. I
have my pop and flow po. I have a video
of the performance on my iPad that I'm
going to be consulting. And I think my
first course of action here is going to
be to block out the uh performance. You
know, I'll do the first four count
together, then I'll do the second four
count together, so on and so forth, and
see if I can work my way through the
entirety. So, I'm going to go ahead and
pull up the video right quick. So, 8
count number one is going to be
5, 6, 7, 8. Lights on three, swings out
the poi on five. Cool. So, let me do
just that much. We do the thing. Pull it
out over here. Light it up. After it
gets lit, there's that whoosh to push
the person away. Right. One that
switches. And we go around to Okay,
that's doable.
[Music]
Hey, I think that was it. Cool. Let's
take a look at the next four count.
First eight count is butterflies.
[Music]
Oh, that's interesting. So, measure five
is in 68. No wonder that Q was so odd.
And that takes us into
weaves. And it looks like waist straps.
And then I throw. Let's try this again.
Oh my god.
Ow, man. I really, really, really hate
behind the back weaves in general.
Oh my god. What is going on with that
bloody behind the back weave? Not going
to choke. Come on. Okay, that's the
reach. that's happening there. That's
annoying. Once more on this and then
we'll move on to the next section here.
I'm not going to get this precisely and
I'm making my piece with it now.
[Music]
Anyway, I'm going to continue on here. I
can't afford to lose much more time. So,
I light this other guy up and then Tuck
turns, swings it over the guy's head,
stops it. Oh, and comes back around and
switches hands. Got it. Okay. So, that
whole sequence, if I'm not mistaken,
then is we swing towards the invisible
man. We swing back over the head, back,
and I think it'll be around up. We do
the somersault.
And as we come back up, it's one of
those. And then back the other way.
Let's try that with music.
[Music]
Missed a bunch of cues there.
God help me. I think the sound cues are
actually starting to make a little bit
of sense. Uh, in case you're curious,
the reason I'm not doing the rolls is
the same reason I'm not going to do the
bridge in just a second is cuz going
upside down tends to give me dizzy
spells. So, um, I'm going to save that
for when time comes to actually shoot a
performance video around this stuff. But
be patient, it's coming.
[Music]
There's that wrap under the legs to
one-handed butterfly and a dramatic
pose. That's the inversion. He's there a
good long while.
Throws one, catches it. Four beat
fountains. Comes out of it. Turn on his
head. Ducks around. Takes a bow. I'm
actually nearly at the end of this.
Which direction is he doing his
fountains?
Counterclockwise, of course. Okay. So,
let me let me walk myself through this
then. So, as we're doing this forwards
weave comes around like that.
cross thing. I come on up. I'm giving
myself permission not to use my left
hand as the one hand here. But I'm going
to nonetheless do the thing from here.
I'm going to go ahead.
This is going to be fun. There's our
inversion. And then there's
really fast. No, it's the other way.
Fountains around
and
[Music]
something like that. I think I got to be
way more dramatic in that pose. Back
bend forever in a day. And the throw. I
forgot theing throw. Back and forth.
Back and forth. Da da da. And throw.
[Music]
Hey friends. So, the camera that I was
using to document all this died. Uh, in
the midst of all of that rehearsal, I'm
not feeling strong about the cues in the
back third of the song and I'm going to
take the L. So, what I'm going to do is
I'm going to book the studio again early
next week. I'm going to come back in and
I'm going to do my best to put down a
good run of this performance. Keep your
fingers crossed for me. We're going to
go from learning it in 2 hours to
learning it in 3 hours. As it turns out,
there's more going on in here than I
thought. And sometimes that is the price
of hubris. So we'll be back then.
All right. So
confession time. Um
it was really disappointing last week to
be where I was at the end of that
session. And um I almost gave up on this
project entirely. The thing that saved
it is I went back and checked the last
take I had of me trying to do the whole
performance and I realized I wasn't that
far off. So, I'm going to try for
another bite at this apple. I'm going to
go back into the studio. I've got
another 2 hours booked and um this time
around I'm going to put a little bit
less pressure on myself to like deliver
the thing and just see how close I can
get today and trying to have some fun
with it. So, let's see how that goes.
All righty then. I am back in the studio
as you can see. So I think that my first
course of action is just going to uh
mark things through and um make sure
that uh I remember everything that I
learned last time. Go ahead and pull it
up.
[Music]
Tuck turns roll
around the feet the back bend
throw
fountain roll and the finish. All right,
let me try that with the poi and see how
it goes.
[Music]
So, just to fill you all in, I'm doing
something a little bit different this
time around. Um, I just took the take
that I did and I sent it to my computer
and I'm going to set it up to play
alongside the circus clip and see how
close I am.
I'm early. Yeah, I'm super early in the
beginning here.
Counterclockwise. He spins
counterclockwise. Bloody hell. Let me do
another run here and see how Let's see
if I can tighten up the timing on some
of this stuff.
[Music]
All right, let's see how take two turned
out.
A little bit early on the butterflies.
Yeah, so that back half is rough right
now. Really rough. So, I really need to
be listening out for the don't don't
more uh as cues here because I keep
being a little early.
[Music]
I feel like I'm still totally clueless
in the counts in the back half. Yeah,
it's right over, left, over. All right,
so this three beat weave here, it's
right over left. So the three beat weave
is always right over left here. How many
times did you do the behind the back
thing? So Oh,
one beat behind, two beats in front, one
beat behind, and then we have the throw.
[Music]
Oh my god, Drex. O, delete that.
So we have over once, over twice, over
again, uh uh and then we have D.
Boom. Okay. All right. Let me try this
one more time. And with 20 minutes left
in the studio, I think it's going to be
time for me just to shoot some video and
see how close I can get.
[Music]
See how that was.
Friends, I think we're ready. All right,
camera is set. Let's do this.
[Music]
We're going to need to try that again.
Ah, come on, kid. You can do better than
this.
[Music]
We're getting there. I need to be a
little bit more gentle in those tumbles.
Damn it. Come on, kid. You can do this.
You can do this.
[Music]
[Applause]
my back.
All right, so I'm overtime by 10 minutes
in the studio here. I have a take that
can work.
I want to get in one more.
[Music]
Well, unfortunately, it wasn't perfect.
Um, but it's as close as I think I'm
going to get in 4 hours. So, uh, I'm out
of time. I'm going to say my work for
the day is done.
All right, so I am back home. It is the
day after and I've had a chance to go
look through all those videos from
yesterday. So overall, I think I did
pretty good considering I only gave it
like three or four hours. And also too
that I'm just like learning off of a
video that I found on YouTube instead of
like having somebody from the company
walk me through how to do it part by
part. This is a fun exercise and though
there are definitely some parts that I
can see that uh were a little rough and
that I wish I'd gotten a little bit
closer on, uh I'm also pretty happy with
what I got given the amount of time that
I invested into it. I hope that this
gives some of you out there watching
some confidence to try this out for
yourself. Who knows, maybe you're the
ones that passed the audition and
someday I will be in the audience and
get to clap you on as you do this
performance on stage. And now, without
further ado, the best take I got of this
performance.
[Music]
Glory
summer.
[Music]
for the summer.
I am
[Music]
How do you think I did on this one?
Leave me a comment and let me know. Let
me know where I could have improved and
also what are the spots that uh I did
pretty dang good on. And for those of
you out there who will be applying for
this particular job, hey, best of luck.
Please be sure to like, share, comment,
and subscribe to help other people find
this video and to help my channel grow.
This video and all the videos on this
channel would not be possible without my
amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a huge
shout out to my FL patrons who are
listed on screen right now. Thank you so
much. You all rock. And if you would
like to get your name in the credits or
access to a host of other awesome
rewards, including uh a weekly lesson
that arrives in your inbox or early
access to content or uh a peek at uh
projects that are in the process of
being developed, uh you can get all that
stuff over at my Patreon at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo.
I'll leave a link to it down in the
description as well as up in the cards.
Please go check that out. help me out
and support me in my mission. And if
you'd like to check out some of the
other awesome boy challenges that I have
done over the years, I'll go ahead and
include a link to a playlist of those
videos down in the description as well
as up on screen. Thank you so much for
watching. Make sure to get out and flow
yourselves today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon. Take care. Peace.